Joe Biden stated that he's seen and
confirmed that children have been
beheaded in in Israel following the
terror attack by Hamas there are still
many people who are skeptical and I
think that's still fair but at this
point we have CBS news saying that
they've gotten word from emergency First
Responders in Israel and uh Joe Biden is
making this claim it is still entirely
possible just look I I remain skeptical
skeptical but uh uh I mean it's it's
it's it's it's tough right we saw what
they did we've I watched another video
today of of Hamas killing civilians
these videos they exist you can watch
them well certainly some of these videos
are probably fake and repurposed there
are some that are undeniable so when you
hear that uh children have had their
heads
removed I mean the challenge is it's
like it's it's more believable than any
claim we've heard in a long time now
with Joe Biden saying it I'm not about
to start believing Joe Biden or the
mainstream press